bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce vendredi
la sécurité en question pour les
humanitaires dans l'est du tchad un
français a été assassiné hier victime de
bandits qui ont pris pour habitude de
s'attaquer aux convois dans cette région
bernard kouchner a demandé une enquête
sur cette affaire
il y a un an déjà la petite maddie
disparue c'est au portugal dans une
chambre d'hôtel victime puis suspect ses
parents les époux mccann
après un long silence ont repris la
parole à la télévision
l'occasion ce soir de faire le point sur
l'enquêté le grand format de ce vendredi
avec un reportage au coeur des centres
éducatifs fermés ses sens sont destinés
à éviter la prison aux jeunes mineurs
délinquants
l'illustration ce soir avec un centre
pour jeunes filles violentes elles ont
14 15 ou 16 ans et ont déjà été condamné
à plusieurs reprises témoignages la
suivre à suivre également une enquête
scientifique sur un outil de travail qui
nous concerne tous nos claviers
d'ordinateurs sont ils venus à microbes
eh bien préparez vous au nettoyage la
réponse est oui nous verrons dans quelle
proportion
enfin dans les jours qui ont précédé mai
68 la france apparemment s'ennuyer
retour à la fin de ce journal en images
et en archives sur l'avant crise une
france en apparence assez sage et bien
loin de la révolte qui allait embraser
le pays
vous le verrez merci d'être avec nous
pour l'actualité de ce vendredi avant de
revenir sur l'ensemble de ces titres on
commence par le verdict rendu
aujourd'hui dans la sphère madison je
vous rappelle que cette petite fille de
5 ans avait été enlevée puis assassinée
dans le village provençal des guerres
l'accusé âgé de 26 ans avait avoué le
meurtre de l'enfant il a été aujourd'hui
condamné à 30 ans de réclusion
un verdict accueilli par les cris du
père de la victime stéphane despinoy
christophe la rocca à l'énoncé du
verdict le père de madison ne peut plus
se retenir
il déverse un torrent d'injures sur le
meurtrier de sa fille est tout le long
du procès il n'a eu qu'un regard haineux
pour julien cariou et selon lui 30 ans
de réclusion dont 18 incompressibles ça
n'est pas assez
c'est à dire des joueurs l'appareil
devrait pas sur sa personne de faire et
pourquoi et comment et voilà moi je
voulais le maximum son avocat tout ça
vous dit dans l'esprit d'un père de
famille qui a perdu son enfant dans les
conditions que nous connaissons je pense
qu'il aurait été plus aisé pour ses fans
qu'à celle de sortir de cette salle
d'audience en sachant qu'il était
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité et non pas à la réclusion
phénomène à 30 ans présenté comme un
mythomane gros consommateurs d'alcool et
de stupéfiants l'accusé a reconnu avoir
enlevé puis étouffé la petite madison
sans jamais expliquer son geste
dans le passé il avait bien tenté de
séduire la maman mais que s'est il alors
passé ce soir de mai 2006 de ce
douloureux procès la maman de madison
elle sort épuisé mais satisfaite
l'avocate de julien carrié aussi tout en
plaidant le coup de folie elle a reconnu
que le crime était impardonnable en
temps pour ma part c'est et une ligne
espérer quoi qu'il en soit à l'issue de
sa peine julien carillon ne devrait pas
tomber sous le coup de la loi dati sur
la rétention de sûreté la petite madison
n'ayant pas subi de sévices sexuels dans
le nord de l'italie les familles des
cinq français qui ont trouvé la mort en
montagne dans le piémont sont arrivés
sur place aujourd'hui
discrètement le guide qui a survécu au
drame a été entendu par les enquêteurs
et ce sont plusieurs versions des faits
qui désormais semble se confronter
explications denis sébastien thierry
monnier il va mieux et a pu être entendu
par la police ces deux carabiniers
viennent de passer une heure avec le
guide français qui a survécu à
l'accident
une audition à l'hôpital d'aoste dans le
cadre de l' enquête ouverte pour
comprendre les circonstances du drame
selon l'un de ses collègues qui a passé
du temps avec lui aujourd'hui le guide
leur a confirmé que son groupe a été
victime d'une avalanche d'accorder a été
emporté par une coulée de neige qui
du dessus était au dessus d'eux et qui
avec la puissance avec la vitesse de la
neige n'avait pas forcément besoin d'un
gros volume la vitesse les a emportés au
dessus des veaux des barres rocheuses
qui était en aval le guide est formel et
pourtant sa version ne coïncident pas
tout à fait avec les observations des
secouristes
didot blanket qui a dirigé l'opération
de sauvetage selon lui il n'y avait sur
les lieux en amont de l'itinéraire
emprunté par le groupe
aucune trace de coup les tenants de ce
moment des tirs
comment dit-on au dessus en fait il y a
juste à la tâte la trace des skieurs qui
descendait juste avant d'arriver sur la
zone wind et de suez n'a pas rêvé de
voler une certitude
le groupe a dévalé une barre rocheuse
journalistes spécialisés bon connaisseur
du secteur
enrico marta est allé enquêter sur les
lieux lui pense que le guide s'était
légèrement écartés de l'itinéraire et il
n'y a pas des signes pour trouver la
route juste il faut bien connaître ce
n'était pas celui-là ne rentre
absolument cet après midi à l'abri du
regard des caméras
les familles des cinq victimes sont
venues se recueillir à l'hôpital près de
turin où se trouve toujours les corps
des défunts
cela fait déjà un an que la petite
maddie disparaissait au portugal une
affaire qu'elle est très vite faire le
tour du monde
une émotion et puis une suspicion qui
finira par peser sur les parents
l'enfant les époux mccann allait alors
être mise en examen
un an après où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui l' enquête at elle avancé
reporte à la londe maryse burgot si vous
détenez madeleine vous pouvez appeler ce
numéro
la seule chose qui nous intéresse c'est
de leur trouver ses marques
un an après la disparition de leur
fillette au portugal
les époux mccann retrouve les
studio de télévision enchaîne les appels
à témoins et répondre à toutes les
questions même les plus dérangeantes
pourquoi par exemple ont-ils laissé
leurs enfants seuls pendant qu'il dînait
au resto je l' ai déjà dit mille fois je
pensais que ma vie était la sécurité
on ne peut pas aimer plus que je laime
va j'aimerais pris aucun risque s'est
même pas posé la question
on pensait simplement que c'était sans
danger on venait régulièrement vérifiée
l'appartement et c'était comme tous les
soirs très calme
les mccann sont toujours mises en examen
par la police portugaise mail enquête
sur la disparition de cet enfant aux
yeux si particulier est toujours au
point mort en insinuant d'ailleurs que
les mccann aurait accidentellement tué
m'a dit certains journaux britanniques
se sont trop avancé depuis ils ont dû
faire des excuses et verse héros mccann
de lourds dommages et intérêts sept cent
mille euros attribuées au fonds créé
pour retrouver maddie
sur le site officiel de nouvelles photos
dont un montage qui permet d'imaginer
cet enfant avec des cheveux plus courts
les époux mccann se disent aujourd'hui
convaincus que leur fillette de 5 ans
est encore en vie quelque part
l'actualité du jour en grande bretagne
c'est également le résultat des
élections municipales élections locales
aux enjeux comme souvent nationaux on
prend tout de suite la direction de
londres bonsoir maryse burgot on avait
parlé d'une défaite annoncée c'est
finalement une déroute pour le parti
travailliste et pour son premier
ministre demande un échec cuisant pour
les travaillistes la gauche britannique
et est aussi un échec personal personnel
pour le premier ministre gordon brown
c'était son premier test électoral
depuis qu'il a succédé à tony blair ces
résultats qu'il n'a pas réussi à asseoir
sa légitimité
les circonstances ne l'ont pas aidé
crise immobilière créée et financière un
comble pour cet homme qui fut vraiment
l'artisan de certains des succès
économiques de tony blair un mot de ce
duel pour la mairie de l'ombre à gauche
ken livingstone va-t-il sauver son
fauteuil de maire de la capitale
les premiers résultats partiels ne sont
pas encourageants pour ken livingstone
les londoniens semble vraiment vouloir
lui faire payer ses décisions de
multiplier les taxe d'embouteillage use
de pollution le très excentrique est
très conservateur boris johnson pourrait
donc l'emporter ce soir vous savez que
ce journaliste s'est beaucoup fait
connaître par son sens de l'humour c'est
ainsi qu'il a séduite son électorat même
s'il fait amender en regrette mans en
regrettant publiquement certaines de ses
blagues xénophobes à merci maryse les
relations franco américaines sont en
passe d'être au beau fixe après nicolas
sarkozy en novembre c'est au tour de
françois fillon de prôner outre
atlantique une alliance solide entre la
france et les états unis
le premier ministre qui est donc à
washington il y à part l'économie
s'apprête à rencontrer le directeur
général du fmi
dominique strauss kahn helen hughes
olivier robin sont sur place une arrivée
discrète sans fond françois fillon vient
à washington en visite de travail à
chacun son amérique
nicolas sarkozy en visite ici il ya six
mois célébrer elvis presley les valeurs
morales et les grands espaces devant le
comité des juifs américains
françois fillon évoque lui ces séjours
touristiques l'amérique terre d'accueil
ami de la france
les deux pays se comprennent pas nouveau
mieux encore quand le premier ministre
français s'expriment en anglais manager
speak english tout je ne vais pas
seulement parler en anglais pour vous
être agréable les aussi parce que
j'espère que vous serez si mon accent
français
great pleasure fourmies c'est pour moi
un plaisir de retrouver ce pays
magnifique que j'admire énormément which
had mais enormous les opérations
séduction également auprès des grands
patrons américains gros investisseurs en
france
à son agenda encore d'une rencontre avec
dominique strauss kahn le directeur du
fmi plutôt pessimiste sur l'économie
mais la vision du fmi sur les trimestres
qui viennent n'est pas très positive aux
états unis et avec la conséquence du
entendu sur l'europe a particulièrement
la france tous les pays européens
nous attendons à ce que ce sera quand
même assez assez difficile pour sa
première visite aux états unis
la première d'un premier ministre
français ici depuis dix ans
françois fillon ne soit reçu ni au
capitole ni par george bush le poste de
premier ministre n'a pas d'équivalent
ici il rencontrera en revanche les plus
hautes autorités économiques et
financières le président de la banque
centrale américaine la fed
le secrétaire au trésor pour évaluer
avec eux l'impact de la crise américaine
sur l'économie française est au coeur
des discussions économiques du jour à
washington françois fillon évoqué la
question de la monnaie notamment celle
de la surévaluation de l'euro face au
dollar une situation vécue difficilement
par les salariés américains qui vivent
en france les salaires en dollars n'ont
parfois pas suivi la hausse de l'euro
voici donc l'exemple de ces américains à
paris reportage syrie les à caroline
brecht francis goldin est arrivé de san
francisco où il ya 15 ans son lien avec
l'amérique c'est ici qu'elle a
entretenue dans cette librairie
ces richesses fait des ouvrages importés
acheté plusieurs fois par mois
aujourd'hui un véritable luxe
désormais elle feuillette leur fort est
passée par là j'ai confiance chaque de
france
chaque prince est soit en se sentant
plus que les français
et face au billet vert qui s'effondre
pour conserver sa clientèle la librairie
elle s'est adaptée connaissez nous de
faire des prix qui soit équivalent
l'angleterre en amérique donc on perd
énormément nos prix donc déjà en
grignote sur les marges
auteur pour une maison d'édition
américaine française perçoit une
rémunération au dollar l'euro augmente
mais pas son salaire pour un loyer de
1400 euros par mois c'est près de 2000
dollars qu'elle doit débourser le taux
de change est devenu une obsession je
regarde la dollar je travaille je fais
cadre dollars ces savoirs face à la
fonte des revenus les employeurs
américains ont trouvé leur parade
renoncer aux expatriés ou les pays en
eau exemple united airlines a roissy 260
steward et hôtesse sous contrat
américain
la compagnie a choisi et fermer le site
en 2006 eurodisney douze mille trois
cents salariés et seulement une
vingtaine de nationalités américaine
payer en eau mais pour la majorité de la
communauté
le retour autres athlètes x impose en
livre griffiths jeune retraité du
département d'état lui a choisi de
rester
sous conditions ici je vois quand ils
ont un travail et temps complet ces
genres pris ma retraite d'un bison au
venezuela mon épouse et reine aux règles
je pourrais vivre avec ma fonction à
seville mais si à paris ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher aux côtés du travail
française goldin elle a déjà tranché
dans quelques mois elle devrait boucler
ses valises destination les états unis
puis peut-être le mexique
loin très loin de la zone euro économie
toujours le ministère des finances
devrait renforcer les contrôles
préalables à l'ouverture d'un livret à
bercy qui souhaite cependant nuancé les
informations parues ce matin chez nos
confrères du parisien information selon
laquelle il y aurait 8 millions de
fraudeurs qui détiendrait de livrer à la
loi je vous rappelle n'autorise qu'un
seul livret par individu en france parle
maintenant d'un lancement annoncé d'une
nouvelle classe intermédiaire chez air
france dans quelques mois de nouveaux
sièges seront installés sur les vols
long courriers pour un confort a à mi
chemin entre la classe économique et la
classe affaires alors pourquoi ce choix
commercial quelles sont les cibles
explications pauline d'ordi d'un richard
nous sommes en classe économique
les sièges sont relativement serré dix
personnes sur une même rangée des petits
fours pour la classe affaires maintenant
ici les fauteuils s'incline pour la nuit
la classe intermédiaire se veut un
compromis de 10 sièges on va passer à 8
et les ranger s'espaceront du coup les
fauteuils seront plus larges plus
confortable ni les couchettes ni les
prestations de la classe affaires mais
une lumière individuel et une prise pour
l'ordinateur à classe intermédiaire prix
intermédiaire par exemple pour un paris
new york en septembre
comptez 575 euros en classe éco ce
serait autour de 1200 euros en classe
intermédiaire en classe affaires il faut
débourser plus de 2500 euros
le projet pour l'hiver 2010 mais les
voyageurs sont déjà séduit
c'est très bien parce que précisément
mon dieu ne me permet pas de voyager
tout en business donc je connais classe
économique c'est quand même un petit peu
juste l'espace donc ça me plairait
beaucoup lu si on fait 24 heures de
voyage vous aimerez certainement on n'a
plus ses jambes allongées
et plus à son aise comme à la maison
dans son fauteuil en indien principales
clientèles visées par cette nouvelle
classe les hommes d'affaires des petites
et moyennes entreprises
l'enjeu pour air france concurrence est
la première compagnie aérienne low cost
pour business man appelé l'avion elle
propose depuis janvier 2007
des allers retours paris new york à
partir de 1160 euros
kouchner parle d'un acte de barbarie
ignoble et a réclamé une enquête le miz
affaires étrangères réagissait à
l'assassinât hier au tchad d'un
humanitaire français pascal marc linge
travaillé pour l'association save the
children et il a été victime de bandits
qui attaquent de plus en plus souvent
les convois dans l'est du pays
amaury guibert sur les pistes à l'est du
tchad le risque est permanent
la région est cassée zone de guerre et
n'est pas rare de croiser des groupes
rebelles ou des coupeurs de route
les humanitaires sont pour eux des
cibles de choix hier matin un convoi de
trois voitures de l'unicef et de l'eau
entre britannique save the children est
intercepté aux environs de farchana par
des hommes armés des coups de feu sont
tirés tuant sur le coup pascal marlins
chef de mission de save the children
âgé de 49 ans père de deux filles pascal
marc linge était rompue aux terrains
difficiles nous l'avions d'ailleurs
rencontré en 2004 à bagdad
aujourd'hui sa femme témoigne de son
engagement et des précautions qui
prenait ocha
je lui disais que c'était une guerre que
la sécurité était pourtant quelqu'un de
très attentif à la sécurité
il essayait de le faire prendre aucun
risque à personne et avait même mis à
tous les gens qui travaillaient pour lui
donc oui ce qui s'est passé hier matin
le groupe effectué une mission dans le
cadre d'un programme de suivi éducatif
mis en place pour les enfants confiés à
l'arche de zoé le tchad affirme
aujourd'hui qu'une escorte avait été
proposé à l'om j'ai mais celle ci aurait
décliné l'offre
la plupart des humanitaires refuse en
effet tout mélange des genres mais
compte aussi sur la présence de l'eufor
une force européenne de sécurisation
toujours en cours de déploiement
après la mort de pascal marc linge les
agences de l'onu et certaines ong
présentes au
tchad ont décidé de suspendre toutes
leurs activités non urgentes jusqu'à
demain voilà maintenant un jeune homme
qui a été français de 1971 année de sa
naissance dans le morbihan jusqu'à fin
depuis il a été déchu de sa nationalité
le motif de tout cela son mariage aux
pays bas avec un homme explications
edouard baer jan l à palo et patrick
vuille storm en boucle au travail comme
à la ville car les frédéric dirige des
derniers travaux de leur future boutique
dans les beaux quartiers d'amsterdam en
2002 frédéric en polo rayé français 37
ans vient s'installer aux pays-bas il
épouse car le jeune quinqua hollandais
ainsi frédéric obtient la nationalité
néerlandaise
mais aujourd'hui le consulat de france
lui demande de rendre son passeport et
sa carte d'identité française car aux
yeux de la loi française font mariage
n'est pas valable
le fond d'affaires et de l'homophobie ça
veut dire que la france n'est pas
d'accord avec le mariage de deux hommes
tirés et la france ne respecte pas dans
mon choix de me marier avec un autre
abonné à l'orient de parents français
frédéric ce sont aujourd'hui humilié et
en colère sans rejeter pas mon propre
pays par mes propres racines
je suis très attaché à la france ce
chiffre est fier d'être français et je
veux que la france reconnaisse un bon
mariage aux pays bas comme en grande
bretagne en espagne en belgique
le mariage entre deux personnes
homosexuelles et reconnu pas en france
le mari frédéric ne comprends pas pour
les néerlandais
c'est une des i avec une culture très
libre très progressif c'est incroyable
pour nous que ça existe convenait pas 27
pas l'existence de gens aux deux arbres
femme qui vit ensemble vivre son
histoire d'amour et conserver sa
nationalité d'origine c'est possible une
convention de 1965 entre la france et
les pays-bas le prévoit mais seulement
en cas de mariage hétérosexuel la france
n'hésite pas à discriminer ces citoyens
à cause de leur homosexualité
on l'a vu récemment en janvier 2008 avec
la condamnation de la france par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme sur la
question de l'adoption et on voit là à
travers le dossier de monsieur minvielle
que c'est bien
l'homosexualité c'est à dire le mariage
de monsieur minvielle avec un
néerlandais qui n'est pas reconnu en
france à qui aboutit à cette situation
totalement absurde et scandaleuse
déchu de sa nationalité frédéric mas
viel pourra redevenir français à partir
de mars 2009 s'ils le souhaitent
c'est ce qu'annonce le quai d'orsay ce
soir la convention de 65 est en cours de
dénonciation par l'état français
le grand format de ce vendredi elles ont
14 15 ou 16 ans et elles sont toutes
délinquante des jeunes filles qui ont
été placés dans un centre éducatif fermé
cela afin d'échapper à la prison
une petite structure qui vise à renouer
les fils du dialogue ou des cours sont
prodigués et qui entretient l'espoir
d'un nouveau départ même si comme
toujours il n'y a pas de solution
miracle en la matière grand format signé
aurait l'agly main et mathieu berden
elle n'a pas l'habitude de montrer cet
aspect là de sa personnalité
sandra est une jeune fille coquette qui
déteste qu'on la traite de garçon manqué
on va lire mon dossier du fret
on pourrait se demander si un garçon une
fille ce que parfois on est devenu des
garçons préfèrent une fille délinquance
sandra n'est pas fier c'est un juge des
enfants qui l'a placé ici un centre
éducatif fermé exclusivement réservé aux
filles pour éviter le rapport de force
avec les garçons mais ça n'empêche pas
les tensions
tout peut très vite dégénérer
même pour des motifs futiles déjà fille
qui a réussi les trois premiers mois on
dirait qu'on est en maternelle
donc voilà le conflit trois copines et
bien une qui a parlé plus longtemps à
l'autre et voilà l'autre est jalouse et
puis ça finit par les quelques points
bagarre des histoires de gamine entre
les filles qui ont déjà un lourd passé
vols violences avec arme trafic de
drogue mineurs et déjà multi récidiviste
elle n'allait plus à l'école depuis
longtemps ici on leur réapprend les
bases et la confiance en français vous
n'êtes pas si nul que ça non je veux que
vous l'entendiez mais non vous
l'entendez mais vous n'intégrez pas à 15
ou 16 ans certaines ont un niveau de
sixième mais la plupart partagent la
même envie de réussir
elle est pensez vraiment que l'école
n'était pas leur truc qu'elle se rende
combat entre guillemets qui est pas si
bête que ça
quel coup prennent elles prennent
conscience qu'à la mise à prix d'or si
ma mère ne voyait si ma mère savait et
puis je crois que les filles contraire
mon garçon elles ont envie d'apprendre
quand même les filles sont plus colère
quand même ce jour-là on cuisine c'est
sophie et linda qui officie aux cff ont
fait le service à tour de rôle c'est la
règle des contraintes des horaires des
interdits pas si facile à intégrer
cimente alors les sorties les parents la
cigarette
au sommet des stupéfiants avant
l'arrivée puis ça fait partie des
manques aussi que les ont vraiment loin
de chez elle loin de leur famille les
coups de blues sont fréquents au centre
ce soir là après une dispute avec
d'autres filles sandra veut partir
qu'est ce qu'ils sont un canton y avait
progressé dur que nous à l'épreuve c'est
carrément dureté loin de maman que loin
de papa je connais la route de nancy il
dort de voiture
et pourtant le 14 juillet ce domaine là
et tu vas y arriver
les filles restent en moyenne sept mois
ici une sanction qui doit déboucher sur
de nouveaux repères et si possible sur
un projet les projets dolores en a plein
la tête mais à 17 ans elle rêve
simplement d'un quotidien ordinaire
voilà aujourd'hui le nom j'aurais voulu
être au lycée travailler être normal
rentrer chez moi l'après lycée dispute
avec ma mère regrette les joue avec mes
frères être quelqu'un normal tu aimerais
bien tout effacer et recommencer sans
les erreurs pour dolores comme pour les
douze jeunes filles placées ici depuis
un an le centre éducatif fermé c'est
peut-être l'occasion d'un nouveau départ
mais une fois dehors tout reste à faire
une enquête scientifique qui devrait
vous intéresser un biologiste
britannique vient d'examiner au
microscope 30 clavier d'ordinateur on va
dire représentative dans un bureau
londonien
l'enjeu l'hygiène de cet outil de
travail devenues tellement indispensable
bien le résultat et vous allez voir
surprenant et même parfois inquiétant
laurence de cercles mathias second
devinette qu'est ce qui contient encore
plus de germes que la cuvette des
toilettes
le clavier de votre ordinateur une étude
scientifique britannique révèle qu'il
abrite ni vu ni connu plus de bactéries
que la moyenne des sièges des water
closet
la raison nettement moins nettoyer les
claviers sont en plus souvent de vrais
garde-manger
du devoir
donc il serait l'ordinateur
et la nuit avant des miettes qui tombent
par exemple de mieux j'ai même remarqué
quand vous prenez un clavier comme ça
quelquefois et que vous leur en versier
ya pas mal de choses qui tombent sur la
table utilisez les ultraviolets pour
éclairer le clavier et vous pouvez voir
la débats stériles et les graisses
appareils et les méchants de bactéries
se sont multipliés à gogo rarement
déloger elles peuvent ensuite se
propager facilement et fut si vous
éternuez ou si vous vous couchez vous
projeter des virus sur le claverie ce
qui peut propager les rhumes et même
pire si vous allez aux toilettes et que
vous ne vous l'avez pas les mains vous
avez des sortes de bactéries alors
yat-il danger on trouve une multitude de
germes qu'ils ont des germes qui
éventuellement chez des personnes
susceptibles peuvent donner des
infections mais pas dans la population
générale alors ce sont des streptocoques
des staphylocoques tout germe avec
lesquels on vit au quotidien
heureusement le l'être humain est bien
adapté à se défendre contre le géant qui
rend compte alors pas de panique pour
éviter que votre clavier ne devienne un
zoo seule solution le nettoyer un peu
plus souvent et se laver les mains
régulièrement aller au boulot tout faire
soi même ou presque faire son pain sa
confiture ou ses glaces est devenue une
véritable tendance vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à vouloir consommer des
produits sains mais il ya aussi une
autre raison à cet engouement dans les
allées de la foire de paris qui vient de
s'ouvrir l'ambiance est à l'économie
françois jullien peignoir et catherine
juste ton compte
la farine la levure et l'électricité le
panda kg il vous revient à 92 centimes
d'euro à ils ont bien compris les
vendeurs à la foire de paris que cette
année on attirer le chaland en parlant
économie voici la première machine à
fabriquer des mini baguette moins chers
que dans le commerce
à la peau augmente de suivre la baguette
la machine coûte 150 euros 1 euro 1
heure 15 à bayonne c'est amorti en six
mois mais bon
trois heures par jour les ventes de
machines à pain ont été multipliées par
3 l'année dernière le plaisir de faire
soi même bien sûr mais aussi de
grappiller quelques centimes par shu en
termes de pouvoir d'achat effectivement
c'est une préoccupation qui revient
régulièrement cirque asie en termes de
de pourcentage des avoirs
trois à quatre personnes sur dix il va
venir me voir et qui me dit mais oui
mais combien fabriquer des talia tel
dans sa cuisine même si le prix des
pâtes a augmenté de 30% en trois ans eh
bien ce n'est pas encore rentable
paraît-il en revanche se concocter des
confitures comme sa grand-mère et sans
le moindre effort c'est plusieurs pots
de gagner avec ce confiturier confiture
environ 4 euros en faisant sa confiture
soi même à la maison ça vous revient à
si pour le pour le prix d'un là j'ai un
coulis de fraises mélangé avec du sirop
de sucre de canne
je le verse dans mon appareil et une
demi heure plus tard à dia c'est les
prêtres des glaces à volonté pas
d'économies de kilos mais peut-être de
quelques euros
la turbine à glace coûte quand même 600
euros
sinon l'économie
on est tenté du côté du concours lépine
on a trouvé cette lampe à dynamo plus
besoin de piles et pour le portable ça
peut être utile je recharge mon
téléphone
c'est bien il n'y a pas dit on de
petites économies
68 c'était hier enfin c'était il ya 40
ans et nous avons choisi ce soir de nous
intéresser aux jours qui ont précédé la
crise voici concrètement à travers la
publicité la politique ou encore la
chanson
quels étaient les préoccupations des
français et bien le pays s'ennuyer il
était plutôt assez calme en tout cas en
apparence karine comazzi didier da 1er
mai 1968 aux manifestations de la fête
du travail
les français ont préféré la cueillette
du muguet et non il ne voit rien mais il
n'est pas le seul
le général de gaulle non plus n'a rien
vu venir si l'on en croit ses voeux à la
nation
c'est vraiment avec confiance que
j'envisage pour les 12 prochains mois
l'existence de notre pays un homme
pourtant trouve le climat de paix
suspect pierre viansson-ponté
éditorialiste au monde le 15 mars 68
il voit le calme qui précède les grandes
tempêtes ce qui caractérise actuellement
notre vie publique c'est l'ennui les
français s'ennuie la jeunesse s'ennuie
le général de gaulle s'ennuie ce qu'est
un coude à verte à l'opinion mais qui
n'a pas été préparée par l'ensemble de
la révélation le direction à l'époque
bernard lausanne était chef du service
société au monde il se souvient d'une
france qui voulait goûter un repos
mérité
venait de lâcher l'algérie ans venait de
perdre les l'afrique et l'indochine bien
avant donc la france était réduite à
l'hexagone la guerre du vietnam et me
les français mais elle ne les touche pas
vraiment écrit encore viansson-ponté en
deux tiers des foyers ont désormais la
télé mais plus que le reportage de
guerre pour les france l aventure
c'est la série dandy
et la vertu
france a besoin de grandes idées de
grandes utopies de de se mobiliser de ne
croire en quelque chose et là voilà
c'est une petite bourgeoise replète plan
plan la france est issu satin tum
faussement mièvre numéro un au hit
parade de salut les copains le pays
s'occupe à s'équiper lave-linge frigo
les femmes découvrent le confort n'est
pas encore là ni verte
on les a enfermés dans l'image de la fée
du foyer l'ange du foyer on disait enfin
bon une magnifique maîtresse de maison
à partir des années 50 après la guerre
est là peut-être que commence à se
ressentir une certaine lassitude
les femmes ont des revendications et pas
forcément celle de la réclame elles
viennent tout juste d'obtenir le droit
de travailler et d'ouvrir un compte en
banque sans l'autorisation de leur mari
mais leur désir de contestation c'est
leur enfant qui le manifesteront avec
l'ardeur et l'imagination que réclamez
l'éditorialiste du monde 19 avril 68 à
la télé le jeune jacques dutronc
regardez cette violence
quelques jours plus tard la capitale
sortait bruyamment de son sommeil
l'image de la flamme olympique qui est
de retour en terre chinoise elle était
aujourd'hui à hong kong un parcours de
sept heures des dizaines de milliers de
personnes s'étaient rassemblées
une vingtaine de militants pro tibétains
en effet tout de même interpellé sport
avec du football et la chute brutale
hier soir du bayern de munich de franck
ribéry face au zénith de saint
pétersbourg le score 4 à 0 et cela en
demi finale de la coupe de l'uefa est la
finale opposera les russes aux écossais
les glasgow rangers se sont imposés face
à la fiorentina le sport toujours à nos
chances de médaille pour les jeux
olympiques il y a les stars et puis il
ya les autres ceux qui se prépare dans
l'ombre jusqu'au jour j
voici ce soir le portrait d'amélie cazé
cette jeune picarde pourrait briller
dans une épreuve danse le pentathlon
moderne elle est déjà championne du
monde et rêves d'or olympique reportage
manuel tissier et guillaume michel la
prof de sport est une championne
championne du monde de pentathlon
moderne et même si la discipline ne fait
pas les gros titres il y a de quoi
impressionner les collégiens pendentif
éclat cependant un progrès ps qui est
champion du monde de pentathlon
gentille pas toujours amélie cazé à cinq
visages tirs escrime équitation natation
course à pied cinq épreuves qui ont fait
de cette picarde de 22 ans l'une des
meilleures chances françaises de podium
olympique
la médaille d'or de berlin attend une
petite soeur à pékin je reste lui si dur
est simple je m'entraîne tous les jours
aussi de manière sereine et il n'y a pas
que les jeux et c'est très important
mais si je commence à y penser
maintenant c'est le meilleur moyen
d'aller dans le mur
amélie cazé évite au pas de charge à
l'insep
la jeune fille passe d'un entraînement à
l'aise avec une épée et son maître
d'armes
elle travaille les assauts qu'elle devra
livrer trente cinq combats d'une minute
au jo
en compétition les pentathlètes doivent
aussi avalé en une journée 3000 m de
cross-country
1 200 m nage libre plus le tir plus
l'équitation
bref pas beaucoup de place pour les
loisirs
une de ses grandes qualités c'est
qu'elle arrive à se détacher un petit
peu de ce qu'on pourrait penser de ce
qu'on peut dire ce qu'espèrent les gens
son entourage ses amis pour elle et elle
aussi être capable d'être au travail
d'être au taf toute la journée à deux
pas de l'insep la garde républicaine
amélie cazé monte à cheval depuis son
plus jeune âge
mais ici elle goûte la rigueur des
instructeurs militaires l'or olympique
se niche dans les détails t doit faire
déjà titulaire du capes mademoiselle
casey et moins martiale avec ses élèves
mais tout aussi appliquée pas question
n'est négligé à bord de notre semble
intéresser davantage dans un bol d'air
l'époque est très fin mai
le 22 août prochain
ok amélie cazé tirera ses premières
cartouches et elle n'aura qu'une journée
pour transformer le plomb en or de la
danse contemporaine à l'opéra de paris
avec un balai qui nous plonge dans
l'andalousie des années 30 une
chorégraphie minimaliste créé par le
suédois mats ek inspiré de la pièce de
frederico garcia lorca la maison de
bernarda alba
reportage à del mostefa et bruno vignais
il faut imaginer un coin aride
d'andalousie
la maison de bernarda et de ses cinq
filles coupé de la vraie vie car
derrière les persiennes après le décès
de son mari la veuve a décrété un deuil
de 80
de plus près voici donc la sévère
bernarda en fait un homme choix du
chorégraphe
mats pec une présence masculine je pense
pour donner une force une force de
caractère donc je pense que ça c'est
plutôt une chose qui est voilà qui est
qui réussit et qui aide aussi vraiment à
camper le personnage bernarda la
tortionnaire
bernard da la dévote
une des filles de bernarda au delà même
de l'interdît avec le prétendant de sa
propre soeur
autant de thèmes et de situations puiser
par le chorégraphe dans la pièce de
garcia lorca
je ne parle pas seulement d'oppression
mais aussi de convoitise de désir de
liberté en fait il y à de multiples
résonances alors que c'est une histoire
qui se déroule dans un lieu clos le soir
par l'absence de la mère l'un des rares
moments de liberté pour les filles est
la bonne l'un des rares moments de
légèreté aussi dans ce ballet qui prend
aux tripes
la maison de bernarda alba l'opéra c'est
la dernière pièce de garcia lorca écrite
peu avant son exécution par les
franquistes et un chorégraphe briand qui
la fit revivre
un spectacle à suivre à l'opéra garnier
jusqu'au 11 mai avant de terminer
journal je vous au rappel l'une des
principales informations
le verdict dans la sphère de la petite
madison l'accusé âgé de 26 ans a été
condamné par la cour d'assises des
bouches du rhône aujourd'hui à 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle donc à 18 ans
incompressibles voilà pour l'actualité
de ce vendredi merci est fidèle à
l'information sur france 2 demain je
vous retrouve pour l'information
justement dès 13h avec le journal et le
magazine dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez 20h50 votre saga le
silence de l'épervier avec line renaud
puis esprit libre yves durand passé une
très belle soirée et à demain
l'info en continu est aussi sur france 2
point fr